Now last but not least is the Take Recorder section.
So we're going to use the Take Recorder plugin to record our crowd simulation.
Now as of Engine 4.27, the Take Recorder plugin is by default enabled, but if for some reason
you're using an older version or you accidentally disabled it, you can go to Settings, Plugins,
type in Take Recorder, and as you can see it's already enabled for me, but you can enable it.
Restart, save your project, and come back you'll be good to go.
Now before I open up the Take Recorder plugin, I first want to take advantage of the retargeted
characters that we spent all this time working on earlier in this class.
So let's change our crowd to be not just mannequin characters, right?
So I'm going to go to the Infinity Blade Warriors folder, go to Character, Complete Characters,
and let me grab the golden retargeted character, and then just use the same technique with
the left arrow button next to the skeletal mesh details panel on the right.
Click that left arrow button and then the mesh hot swaps just instantaneously, and then
I'll click another crowd character or another crowd agent, and let's put the shell retargeted
character on him using the same left arrow technique.
And maybe on this guy we'll find another cardboard character and put him on there,
and then in the very back let's put the golden guy on there.
Okay, so there is our crowd, and let's actually get the Take Recorder to show up.
So all you have to do is go to Window, Cinematics, Take Recorder, and then you should see the
Take Recorder tab open up and the Sequencer tab.
Now I was messing with the interface and normally by default the Take Recorder is a little bit
bigger, but I made my level viewport window larger so that I could see my play button,
which is going to be important because you have to hit play before you can record.
I mean the record button is kind of grayed out right now.
There's no sources for it to record so there's not much for it to do.
So let's add some sources.
Now I have one crowd character selected.
I could right click on it, go to Select, Select All Crowd Characters, and then that way if
I do that and click right there, all of those characters are selected except for the third
person guy, which is what we want.
And then another way to do that is if I click on one of the crowd people I do Ctrl Shift
A, same thing, and then similar to the sequencer where you have a plus track button and then
you can add actors.
In the Take Recorder you can add a source for it to pay attention to for it to record.
So I'm going to hit the plus source button from Actor, Add Current Selection.
So now our crowd of five people is going to get recorded.
Now I mentioned you have to play first and then record, but the record part's a little
tricky sometimes.
So if I hit play, alright, I'm just doing my thing, I'm playing the game, but if I try
to move my mouse over to the Take Record section, I'm having a hard time getting to the record
button.
So in order to eject temporarily from the game and then record, there's a hotkey.
I want you to remember it's F8.
Now my mouse is free, I can hit record and then we have this countdown delay and then
it's recording something and then I hit stop.
And then I'm still playing, let me hit escape.
And now I'm back to where I was.
And then you might be wondering, okay, where did my take go because I saw it two seconds ago.
In order to see the most recent take, you go up to the top of the take recorder and
there's this icon that says review the last recording.
It looks like a film strip with a little eyeball.
And then now we can see our take.
So we've got more characters in there because we've got the characters that live in the
level normally, but we've also got the recorded versions that are spawning in there from the sequencer.
Now what if I don't want that delay?
You know, the countdown, the 3-2-1 that we saw earlier?
It's useful if let's say you're wearing a motion capture suit, but you're also the one
operating at the computer and you need some time to run back to your starting mark.
But you know, we're not doing that.
So in order to change that, let's use this return back to the pending take arrow so that
we can get ready for a new recording.
And then this show hide settings option right here looks like a bunch of gears.
If you click on that and you scroll all the way down to user settings, change countdown to zero.
And now as soon as you hit the record button, it will not have that countdown delay anymore.
So if your motion is fast, it's really helpful so you don't accidentally miss part of the motion.
So let's try this again.
I'm going to hit play and then I'm going to hit F8 record.
Let it record for a bit.
Okay, stop record, stop playing.
And then let's go back to the take that we recorded by using the review the last recording button.
And here we are.
Now I can actually double click on these individual tracks and go inside and see what it recorded.
There's an animation track and then we've got the motion.
It gets keyframed on the transform track.
And if I actually go up and unlock this scene up in the top right, now the red outlines
disappear and when I double click inside of a track, I could actually adjust a lot in here.
I could shorten the animation.
I could delete keyframes.
I could make a character hold in a certain position for much longer than it already does.
Or let's say in the scene 1 underscore 2, I like all of the motion except for character
5.
Well, you know what?
I could just delete him and we're fine.
And in fact, we could just delete that crowd character 5.
And then we've got a curated scene of just four extras.
Now if it's a little hard to decipher what's going on because we've got twice the number
of crowd people, we can go to the world outliner, which again is just like a table of contents
for what's in your scene.
We can hide the crowd people that are not currently being driven by the sequence that
we recorded.
And if you're wondering, okay, well, how do I know which ones those are?
So if there's not a lightning bolt icon, then it's a normal character that's living in the
level all the time.
But if it has this lightning bolt, it means the sequence is spawning it into the level
temporarily.
And so I'm just going to hide the original crowd people.
Now this is what we're actually seeing in the level.
And it looks like we've got one mannequin that snuck in there.
And then if we examine this a little bit further, I'm just clicking inside one of the tracks.
If I right click on the animation clip and I go to properties, this will tell you, hey,
this is where that animation clip was recorded.
And we know it's under games, cinematics, takes, etc, etc.
Or you could just double click on the square itself with the image.
And then we can see the walking animation.
It's just walking in place.
And then all of the transform information is what's moving the character to and fro
the space.
But if you wanted, and if your characters had different animations, maybe one was walking,
one was running, you could swap these out.
And if you want to know where the sequences live, we can go to content browser.
And let's go to cinematics, takes, and it's got a folder generated for us based on today's
date.
And then we've got the different level sequences.
And then we've got different sub scenes for each of those level sequences.
And in here, we've got our animation.
And then if I go back up here is the crowd character too.
Let's double click on that.
So it's broken up into different animation clips and level sequences.
And then if I'm ready to record yet another take, I can go to the return back to the pending
take button.
And then we're off to the races.